well speaking of expanding influence
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
told leaders from African States meeting
in Saint Petersburg that Moscow is
forgiving 23 billion dollars of debt
owed by them Putin is also promising to
maintain grain supplies to the continent
and to increase Russia's diplomatic
presence there he's blaming the West for
high food prices and inflation after
printing money during the pandemic Putin
says the global economic system is going
through significant change
the African continent is indeed becoming
a new center of power its political and
economic role is growing exponentially
everyone will have to take this reality
into account for example let's look at
the initiative by a number of African
States on solving the Ukraine crisis
which is an acute problem we are not
shying away from reviewing it previously
any mediation missions were monopolized
exclusively by countries with so-called
Advanced democracies not anymore now
Africa is ready to help solve the
problems that seem outside its primary
interests we treat your initiatives with
respect and carefully study them
well let's speak to our correspondent
Ali Hashem he joins us now from that
Summit in Saint Petersburg Ali some very
interesting rhetoric there today from
Putin what do you make of the tone
well Anastasia it seems very clear that
Putin and Russia are setting their
priorities for the next uh several years
Africa now isn't just a place to invest
or just a place to have security
presence or a place to have diplomatic
ties there are plans for Africa and this
is what Putin said in his opening speech
yesterday he made several initiatives
and today it's clear also from his
second speech he yesterday he met all
the leaders today he met seven leaders
in the morning the ones carrying the
Ukraine initiative you can please plan
and now he is at this time meeting all
the leaders once again so three meetings
with all the leaders of Africa most of
the leaders who are attending 17 leaders
out of 54. now yesterday there were
several initiatives today also he
mentioned the role Africa is going to
play alongside Russia and other
countries in creating a new world order
a just world and also he recalled the
role the Soviet Union used to play in
Africa in building energy plants and
building factories and inside that
Russia wants to play this role once
again
Ali do we have a sense of moscow's
intentions behind the many gestures of
Goodwill that have been announced
well it's it's the struggle for Africa
the big struggle for Africa and West
China Russia Iran many many countries
are trying to have to set their foot in
Africa to have a footprint in Africa and
we've been hearing in the past years on
the Wagner Group which is a Russian Guru
that's been involved in security matters
whether in car in Central African
Republic in Sudan in Libya in Malibu
Burkina Faso and today there are kind of
hints or
analysis or accusations for the Wagner
group of being a kind of implicated in
what what's happening in in Niger so the
the Russians have Ambitions in Africa
the the previous Ambitions of the Soviet
Union are now carried by the by
President Putin's government and it
seems that this forum that's
concluding its uh activities today this
Summit was one of the main Bridges to
start this new initiative towards Africa
very interesting times Ali Hashem they
had that Summit for us in Saint
Petersburg thank you Ali